what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be talking about um
i would say like a slight
criticism i have of kevin samuels um
overall like i like his content i think
i agree with more probably than i
disagree with him
um but this is just one thing that i
think is a little bit ironic about him
so before i start don't forget subscribe
to the channel i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers ring that notification bell
while you're at it
um and yeah okay so
my biggest criticism of kevin samuels
not even like my biggest this is just
one i guess i have
he constantly is preaching to tell
people to like get married stay married
get back with the mother
of your kids whatever um
but he's only been married
for three years and i know
he put out a video recently saying oh
well you wouldn't
like nobody ever asked if steve harvey
was married
um but personally i've listened to a lot
of steve harvey and
i thought i thought the same thing i
thought it was ironic that he was giving
out
um advice after being divorced like
twice or
one time you know like this stuff
happens all the time
um so sometimes i'm a little bit
skeptical just because
like personally i would never go to a
dentist with bad teeth
right um i wouldn't do it i wouldn't go
to an overweight doctor
i think it's really important to go to
people that are actually practicing what
they preach rather than like telling you
what they
you know telling you what to do because
what i found is
there's so many people that just want to
tell you what to do um
and they don't actually want to
give you the advice that's helped them
and i'm not saying kevin samuels is like
a hundred percent like that like overall
i think he's trying to help
but i don't know it just it made me feel
some type of way when i found out that
he'd been married for like three years
total in his
entire life and he's trying to preach
all this stuff about how to make a
marriage work
like that that's kind of weird to me um
but you know there's like hours and
hours of him talking so you never know i
could have missed something
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree
um and let me know what i should talk
about next time